ah
[Música]
bélgica volver a acoger a espectadores
en los campos de fútbol tras más de seis
meses el primero en hacerlo será uno de
los principales clubes del país el
anderlecht en que en los próximos
partidos que juegue en casa acogerá a
más de 6000 personas un tercio de la
capacidad de su campo también otro de
los principales el club es el standard
de lieja que acogerá a aproximadamente
10 mil personas eso sí habrá estrictas
medidas de seguridad gel hidroalcohólico
tanto en la entrada como en la salida
del estadio mascarillas obligatorias y
una distancia entre asientos de mínimo
un metro tampoco podrá haber nadie
sentado ni delante ni detrás a menos que
se conviva con esa persona eso sí los
científicos alertan de que de momento no
se va a seguir ampliando la capacidad de
espectadores en los campos porque al
gritar y al haber grandes multitudes se
puede multiplicar la incidencia del
virus sin embargo el hecho de que los
espectadores puedan volver de nuevo a
los campos de fútbol
da cierta sensación de no
[Música]
el tour de francia llega a su tercera y
última semana y por ahora las medidas
contra el coronavirus están dando frutos
tanto los equipos como los miembros de
la organización están en una especie de
burbuja sanitaria para evitar todo
contagio y se han sometido a varios
tests ps2 antes de que comenzará el tour
y dos durante los dos días de descanso
que hay a lo largo del tour de hecho en
los dos primeros test durante el primer
día de descanso todo el pelotón salió
negativo pero si hubo cinco casos
positivos uno de ellos el de cristian
fue donde el director del tour de
francia que espera poder regresar para
las etapas finales cuando estuvimos en
niza cubriendo la salida del tour vimos
que también para los medios las medidas
eran muy estrictas además del uso
obligatorio de tapabocas que también es
algo que aplica también al público hay
que decirlo y es que el ciclismo es uno
de los deportes que más se cuida de
todos los gérmenes y de los virus
[Música]
con la superliga que es el torneo que
enfrenta a los dos últimos campeones en
regreso el fútbol a colombia esto fue el
martes cuando el partido entre el
américa de cali y el junior de
barranquilla una vez superado ese torneo
y una vez se juegan unos partidos
aplazados la liga colombiana volverá al
completo el próximo fin de semana el fin
de semana del 19 de septiembre una liga
que estaba suspendida desde marzo y que
en esta ocasión se va a extender hasta
el 27 de diciembre de las mismas fechas
de navidad este torneo no volverá con la
presencia de aficionados como ha
ocurrido en otros países pero colombia
se une así a esta larga lista de países
de américa latina que ya han retomado
sus ligas profesionales de fútbol de
hecho colombia era uno de los últimos
países de la región que no había dado
vuelta al fútbol y desde así argentina
como la última gran liga de sudamérica
que no ha regresado con su liga algo que
podría ser un lastre para el fútbol
argentino porque la copa libertadores
regresa el 15 de septiembre y además en
octubre dan inicio a las eliminatorias
sudamericanas para el mundial de fútbol
de qatar 2022 aquí en colombia queda
pendiente todavía la fecha del regreso
de la liga profesional de fútbol
femenino
[Música]